- I am very excited that
you use your platform
to shine a light on things
that maybe not everybody knows about.
This is really cool.
- Well, that's how I
feel about you, as well.
Yes, my manager, who I've been with
since I was literally 14 years old,
been with my entire team since I was
basically 14, 15 years old--
- [Kelly] Wow!
- So we've become very close.
Her son has a very rare disorder,
disease, called EB, EBMRF,
and it's very rare, and
nobody really knows about it.
And we're trying to get the
word out about it, spread some--
- I had never heard about it!
- Most people haven't,
and then you see it and you hear about it,
and it's really tough,
and he lives with this every single day.
And this family is amazing,
and we just wanna find a
cure for this effing thing,
sooner than later.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes! (claps)
- See, the f-word again! (laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- My next guess is a family
that's close personal friends with Kaley
and is coping with a rare illness
that is as tragic as it is mysterious.
Take a look.
- Ooh, hi, kitty!
- I'm Brandon.
I am 15 years old, and I live
in Los Angeles, California.
I have epidermolysis bullosa,
which is a skin condition
that you're born with,
which means I have very fragile skin.
- Basically, you're missing the
gene that produces collagen,
which binds the layers
of the skin together.
- Brandon wants to participate
as fully as he can,
and when he has bad days
and can't get out of bed,
it's just, it's really,
it's heartbreaking.
- And he deals with an enormous challenge
quite gracefully, I think.
- I want people to know that, yeah,
it doesn't define me,
and there's gonna be
good days and bad days,
And I try to just get over the bad days
and just keep hoping for the good days.
- [Andrea] We are amazed everyday
at his ability to just wake
up and deal as best he can,
and life is tough, but so is he.
(claps)
- Y'all, please welcome
(crowd cheers)
Andrea Pett-Joseph, her
husband Paul Joseph,
and their son Brandon.